[Music]
take your minds back to 1994
back when uh sega genesis was a thing
i love psychogenesis did you guys have
second chances yeah i was only allowed
to have one console right after my
nintendo broke and it's like it was
either gen like sega or super nintendo
and i became team
sega because all of my friends had super
nintendo so i could go to their house
and play that
and then they'd come to my house and
play tactic actually yeah
so uh
did you play the sonic the hedgehog
games it comes with it
that was like their mario right yeah
that was their mark package with it so
by the third sonic the hedgehog i don't
know if you guys knew this urban legend
but there was always a rumor back in the
day
that um sonic the hedgehog 3 had music
that was composed by michael jackson no
was it real well nobody knew if it was
real and for the longest time the uh
people always like there were always
stories surrounding it some people did
come out that worked on the project and
confirmed that it was true
but it wasn't until now that the creator
of sonic the hedgehog admitted that it's
true
what does it sound like it's when he
gets the rings huh
you just you just change the pitch
you look back and it's like oh thank you
buddy
no wonder the moonwalker game is on on
sega yes that's one of the main reasons
why i bought six stepped from that deal
like uh sega was doing the moonwalker
game and then there was another game
that uh michael worked on called space
channel 5 which sega owned but
literally the creator of sonic the
hedgehog never said anything about it or
anything why that would have been such
great marketing well
uh why do you think this year so here's
what they're saying they're trying to
bump up the movie yeah yeah probably
what happened was that uh
he was slated to be credited and be like
oh michael jackson made the music for
song three and then the child
allegations came up
i mean in the moonwalker he's constantly
saving children though
[Laughter]
let's listen to some samples of uh the
music from sonic 3 after hearing it like
this these are the actual songs in the
game and they can be directly compared
with actual michael songs that like came
out and you're like
of course it's just thriller
you knocked me off the bob rings baby
[Laughter]
it's the same pattern as stranger in
moscow
so that
took
what quincy jones did because he built
his little stupid
[Music]
doesn't matter if
[Music]
is that the last one oh no there's one
more
dirty diana
oh god
do you think that's a little the reason
why we love michael jackson so much
though is because of kind of phoned it
in huh
it's like buying a happy meal when
you're a child and how hooked you get
with mcdonald's it's like when you get
hooked at that age
you just have that it just has that
effect on you like that's yeah i can see
that michael jackson but it's crazy
because not very many people have that
hook
you know that hook is extremely
difficult like all the artists of his
generation oh yeah yeah yeah michael
jackson like man but the way that he
manufactured his whole thing like
whether it was a team or just himself
like
the look like he wasn't because you know
when he was a child right like it was uh
his dad basically puppeteering
everything but he was just a funk band
yeah he was a great funk musician yeah
but then when he became like michael
jackson i think
what was it after thriller he was like
out of this world he was like oh [ __ ]
well that's what i think is an asset to
if truly michael did think like a child
that's why because he's very creative
well yeah because if you still if you
actually do still like if you never grew
up in your mind in a way you know what
kids are going to like because you're
saying he wasn't child blessing he was
acting his age
well if you if you if you i don't know
that's before they explain that
what are you trying to say at the moment
joe was feeding that in my ear i don't
actually know what you're saying joe no
i i remember dave chappelle was talking
about how
what he is is like
he's like trying to show off but to kids
yeah because then when he has his
carnival he's all just like look at this
[ __ ] i got a monkey man
the kid's like oh i wish i had that he
goes i know you can't have it
did he name his monkey bubbles
that's what a kid would name a monkey he
named his kid blanket that's true that's
what a kid would name a kid
his favorite thing what's your favorite
thing my [ __ ] blanket you would show
the world my little baby outside of a
window even though it's like very
dangerous so babies show other babies
you're right that's how kids show babies
you know you know he does act like a
child yeah it's it's super crazy that
because of what he i guess was accused
of who knows how many other projects
they scrubbed his name from
ha
do you believe it yeah what do you think
you believe wade robson that's a tough
one i mean i think it could very well be
a possibility
um what's the percentage you give on
that just the hawk percentage you know
what i mean don't worry about don't
worry about society
or anybody judging you 90
percent why do you think this is talking
on this why do you think it's such a
huge hospital [ __ ] you guys but go ahead
feel like the amount of oppression
michael probably had as a kid
and
being thrown into that big of the
entertainment business
then the norm for an individual is going
to be so different from a norm in a
normal child that grows up in like a
regular society so of course you're
going to get the good thing but equally
it doesn't make sense not to have the
bad side either you know and i feel like
it's weird when people are like oh but
he's so talented and all this like those
are two separate things they can both
co-exist you know i actually think for
most people i think artists are crazy
i'm like
they need that to make that art exactly
but he doesn't need the [ __ ] breath
of children
i think he was a protector of children
you literally said you'd still love r
kelly yesterday
his music not him his music i don't love
r
kelly that i love to laugh at r kelly
do you want to come too i love to laugh
at r kelly even when our kelly was like
popping i don't think anyone was ever
like i love arcade i like his music yeah
like i love the
is like a saint
he is like wow to me he is like how
convenient because the popes also
condone this thing
god damn it
say michael it's saint michaelis okay
look i don't think it's that crazy to
say look was there a high probability
that mike was out here molesting and you
know really sexually abusing kids
100 percent
100
but does he is he not a musical genius
a thousand percent one million percent
thousand what's so funny about what you
said you just basically said is there a
high probability a hundred percent
if i in my eyes michael jackson molested
and sexually assaulted on what base you
guys just watched a documentary a
feeling dude a feeling look it's not
even does that feeling go oh yeah
it's not even just the documentary yeah
the documentary can be highly biased but
was there footage of mike jackson
hanging around kids all the time like he
just would go to the store and kid like
one kid would just be with him what if
it's the whole thing where he feels like
he's a kid he wants to hang around he's
gonna [ __ ] that makes me more likely
feel like that opportunity presents
itself way more
because he has a kid around him but what
if he doesn't want to [ __ ] him what if
he just wants to hang out yeah mother
teresa was always around children's and
orphans but she didn't [ __ ] him we don't
know [ __ ] remember we found out about
gandhi right that's true oh we found out
about gandhi i'm just saying look we
can't hold we can't put these people on
pedestals as far as like we don't know
what we found out we just found out that
he was he is on a pedestal on a massive
one a musical pedestal like he is like
he is the golden standard but he didn't
make no music and that he had no bangers
and that's why nobody cares dude nobody
cares about ghanaian
garage
[Laughter]
dude hey godly had zero bangers
he had no bangers that's why no one
cares but
mj was on more than a musical pedestal
oh of course
but as far as like what got him to that
massive stage was it like it's
objectively so [ __ ] good and if you
say that michael jackson's not good you
can go [ __ ] yourself
that's what i think you don't actually
know what nick's arguing right now i'm
not i'm arguing both
of the sickest high probability he [ __ ]
some kids who who here um believes more
that it didn't happen then me a thousand
percent
is that too is that like just truthfully
or like to protect
i did my research
i also know someone who knows wade i
know wait
he's like
he's like i know hawk
i know that's what i think makes it
interesting for oxide too that's why you
got to freaking protect your friend your
bias because you know him
honestly that that might play a part
into it also you know but even with all
that because it's hard for me to know
someone and be like you're like sack of
[ __ ] you can't [ __ ] do [ __ ] to you
[ __ ] you yeah you know that person said
michael never did it know what that
person said no he says he believes wade
[Laughter]
wait so because that person said they
believe wade and you don't believe that
person a thousand percent oh okay
because i was like oh really why and he
goes oh cause he's a cool person not
good enough you know who else was a cool
person
you know who was a curtis
many cool people have done bad things i
think we're saying different things but
i think we're on the same side
no we're not
showing let's say you had i'm not
standing with non-michael team my close
friend said
nick michael did it to me
then you would would that sway any of
your belief if he was a close friend
yeah yeah and that guy was like yo mike
[ __ ] sexually like if gilbert was
[ __ ] molested but nick would probably
high five her i'd be like what was it
like no uh [ __ ] no i would have been
like yeah i [ __ ] knew it i'd be like
yeah probably
yeah good shot there's a good shot it
just it's just the odds the probability
of him with just random kids all the
time and then everything that he does
for his free time like involves kids in
my head i'm just like yeah duh what if
what if he had another friend or you had
another friend that said no mike would
never do that he would never do that but
i'll be like
did you hang out with him and he's like
yeah he's like he's like i knew somebody
who knew wade
see that's what makes it harder holly
said they hung out all the time but he's
too high profile dude you can't do that
to mccauley yeah because mccully was a
star but if you're a kid lover right and
you're in a room alone with us with that
version of [ __ ] cindy crawford yeah
wouldn't you just try but you can't hey
but that's the thing though you can't
he
mccully was probably like wise beyond
his years for his age probably right and
he was also very protected because he
was a huge star at the time so he was
like he was like the hottest you're
saying michael would go for groupies
instead of
stuff not groupies but people he could
probably manipulate a little bit more
and get away with yeah exactly you know
what i mean hype less probability and
the thing is i feel like just because it
didn't happen to that person doesn't
make them never do it exactly i feel
like that's a single that's why it's so
difficult also too from our history of
understanding how people like sexually
assault kids and like target them
they're very like selective they're very
predatory you know what you mean so yeah
you guys are pre
as a group as a whole i would like to
say on behalf
of mitzi oh jesus why did you catch you
in the zone so you just go yeah yeah
yeah totally not this what about this
yeah you personally trained a lot of
chicks yeah you don't [ __ ] all of them
why are you around so many chicks i
actually i don't [ __ ] any of them dude
see that's the same thing why are you
around so many people [ __ ] women all
the time what girls hanging out all
these [ __ ] kids but that's when
you're wrong i really don't have that
many female clients
you just said you had a [ __ ] ton
dude it specializes in men's bodies yeah
yeah yeah
so did you [ __ ] the man yeah i do
exclusively
sign up for my training what did wade
tell you that you're like maybe i'm more
on the side it is possible that it
happened oh no i mean i haven't talked
to him personally about it i don't think
i'm in no way of a position a hard thing
to do
hey yo wait what's up man you want to
talk
dm or something
no and i think for me if there is any
bias i feel like it's a subconscious
sort of thing because you like him and
he's your friend oh may maybe but i
think i look more towards the
um you know if you just broadly whether
it be michael or anyone else you know if
you have an upbringing like that and you
have a huge success
the the
likeliness of having that
huge amount of dark side is is highly
possible like how why wouldn't it you
know yeah and whether normal people have
a possibility of having that dark side
so like you put somebody in like some
way with power too with like with huge
power mike jackson was like i keep
following mike jackson it doesn't sound
like like i'm saying michael my dad it's
like it's like somebody else
yeah me and michael way back dude
no but like when he has a lot of power
at the time he was the biggest star in
the [ __ ] world like the world so it's
like you could probably get away with
some [ __ ] exactly and the odds of that
happening like if you just look at
anyone in power in any industry
throughout history you know it's just
the thing that happens not saying that
it's it's good like yeah and obviously
it's a horrible thing but just
statistically
it's it makes sense you know and i have
no evidence and you guys don't either so
i'm just gonna keep
staying my stance and saying he didn't
touch no kids he protects kids and i
think this is going to be a good debate
that we just have from now on yeah we'll
just always have it
at the same point that's what's funny is
is isn't it harder to
believe all the epstein's stuff than to
believe the michael jackson stuff
because epstein doesn't make no bangers
do you mean like garnish my guy bro
you look back and he did release those
couple albums
[Music]
you